what is up guys i'm kim Bhd here and we
got a couple fun reviews right around
the corner as you guys know galaxy note
7 coming right up
the braggy - headphones and a couple of
other things but it's been a little
while since we did a Q&A video as you
know I think so the last Q&A video was
when we were first setting up first
getting into this space and playing some
things together so now that we're on the
tail end of that and most of this stuff
is set up now it feels right to do
another Q&A so I asked you guys on
Twitter what you guys wanted to know
these are best questions and this is
asked mkbhd v10 sponsored by LG because
get it because LG v10 yeah that's a bad
joke why do you use a red weapon dragon
camera if the videos will still get
compressed when they're uploaded to
YouTube same reason you would use your
smartphone 4k camera or a Canon t2i to
shoot when it still gets compressed to
YouTube any video you upload to YouTube
is gonna get compressed but there are
different advantages to different types
of cameras you might use let's say a t2i
for example you can get interchangeable
lenses and you can play with depth of
field and you can play with color and
you can play with dynamic range and
every different camera you get will have
different advantages so I shoot with
this camera because I like the
advantages it has how do you balance
those round edged phones vertically for
those crispy shots you're running a tech
company of your choice for one day
what's the first thing you do okay I'm
gonna pick Apple first thing I do is
probably immediately refresh all of the
desktops that are like out of date like
the Mac Pro I would refresh the Mac Pro
new GPUs new cpus everything immediately
and that i'd probably get one or two for
free since i'm the boss has anyone ever
mentioned that your name sounds like
marques browny yes that was all of
second grade how do you become a tech
reviewer alright so I can't tell you all
of how to become a tech reviewer right
now with what you have today but what I
can tell you is how I became a tech
reviewer which is just by reviewing tech
that I already have and it seems really
obvious but people think like oh I don't
have the money to spend on a whole bunch
of tech to buy and review right now but
neither did
I started in high school when I just
bought one laptop because that's what I
needed for school and I made dozens and
dozens of videos for the next person who
was trying to decide what laptop to buy
for school about the one that I bought
so you might not think you have tech but
you're watching this video on something
you might have a keyboard you like you
might have a mouse you like and you know
that piece of tech better than anyone
else because you're using it so all you
have to do is take out your phone or
take out some camera or some device that
you can use to talk about your
experience and that will help the next
person who's trying to decide what to
buy that's what it all comes down to is
a purchase decision those are the key
words if you can help someone who's
trying to make a purchase you're a tech
reviewer what do you think about the
rumors of the large bottom chin in the
new Nexus yeah okay so if you guys
haven't seen this since the last video
the Nexus type video that I made there's
been a new hardware leak of the new
Nexus a--'s where we get a pretty good
look at what it should actually look
like despite it being so blurry and then
from that you can tell that it's
actually a direct rip it's just a
recycled piece of hardware from a
previous HTC phone which had
front-facing speakers but the new Nexus
doesn't have front-facing speakers so
the top and bottom chins are just really
big that's yeah that's pretty
disappointing to me I kind of wish if
you're gonna have those big chins throw
in some front-facing speakers please in
what ways do you want the quality of
your videos to increase over time okay
yes I there's a bunch of different ways
that you can think of video quality and
from the bigger ways just the editing or
the way the video looks down to the
smaller things like the timing or the
color or little things like that but I
guess generally my main goal as far as
video quality goes is to make as
realistic of a looking video as possible
so there's plenty of other looks you can
have for video that are really
interesting and creative and color
grades that look all crazy and fancy but
you'll notice I rarely do that type of
stuff because I'm trying to make this
look as real-life as possible when I
have a device in my hand outside I'm
trying to make that look exactly like
you're holding a device outside so
that's why you'll see me work on things
like color correction or video
production for that purpose choose one
smartphones with unlimited battery or
globally accessible Wireless Gigabit
connection Wow okay so
both would be a hussam if I can only
pick one I'm gonna say that globally
wireless internet is already pretty good
like I have pretty good internet for the
most part where I'm at so it would be
nice to have global gigabit but I would
definitely pick smart phones with
unlimited battery to never have to
charge this little guy again would be
ideal what was your first subscriber
milestone and how long did it take to
get there
I actually remember my first milestone
is is actually when I made 100 videos my
hundredth video and I actually made my
100th video dedicated to the people who
are watching which was 78 subscribers so
if you ever get down on your own channel
and how many subscribers you have based
on how many videos you have watch that
one so yeah welcome to video number 100
right now I have
I'm gonna check right now right now I
have approximately 70 ish subscribers
what's your opinion on mirrorless
cameras are they good for learning and
can I compete with DSLRs recently I
would say yeah mirrorless cameras are
great I have been messing around with
Sony's recently so the a 6300 is an
amazing video camera for the price
interchangeable lenses 4k video all that
stuff
the a 7s mark 2 is pretty much unmatched
in the DSLR world as far as low-light
video goes so yeah they're great for
learning and they can compete with DSLRs
and sometimes beat them do you put the
note in the bowl first or the serial and
how do you feel about people who do it
differently if you put I think if you
put the milk in the bowl first you
should be evaluated like psychologically
is a camera on the iPhone se good enough
for filming for YouTube and do you have
any other advice for starters like me
thanks yeah my advice would be yes the
iPhone se is a really good camera better
than most have already for shooting
YouTube videos and my advice for
starters is just that get started a lot
of people are thinking about like I said
again what this should do what they
should buy to start making videos or
what they should get together to begin
it's not really about that it's just
about what you make and then once you
make your first few videos then you can
get better from there you'll never start
off with a perfect first video don't
worry about it
it
we'll be better after you get started if
you have the power to release any
product into the world what would it be
or what would it do from any company or
your own okay so I kind of tweeted
something about this like a little
earlier there's two types of people that
I've noticed when it comes to stock
Android the first type that says yeah
it's boring it doesn't really do much I
kind of like having more features and
number two which is yes it's clean its
crisp it's everything functional and
it's beautiful and I love it and I've
fall closer to the second type of person
so I said I would love to see a Google
Play edition galaxy note 7
I would love stock Android on a note
gave me the stylus features back gave me
some of the Samsung features but I
really just want that crisp stock
Android on a beautiful piece of hardware
like this but it'll probably never
happen what does the K stand for so my
full name is marques
you
that's that's what it stands for anyway
yeah that's pretty much it so thank you
very much for watching this one I also
want to give a quick shout out so there
is a article written on the ringer which
is Bill Simmons site and it's about tech
on YouTube and how it's grown in the
past couple years and it's really well
really well written really well done
well researched so I'm going to leave a
link to that article below you can check
it out it's pretty awesome and yeah
that's pretty much it so thanks for
watching this one and I'll talk to you
guys very soon in the next video peace